ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING WILL A-
RULES COMMITTEE IS CALLED ORDER
PLEASE REVISE THE AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS ALSO BE TELEVISED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
THIS HEARING ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISTURBS. DISRUPTS
THE SERVER OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING
VIOLATIONS RULES MAY BE
SUBMITTED INTO THE REMOVED OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESSES.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. COOLEY
WALDRON BANNACK FLORA. FONG
GIPSON. LEVY MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
RUBIO MIMPARA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA- AT I DON'T. IT
WAS A SERVER HERE. MOTION TO
MOVE ON THE CONSENT
COUNTERMEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU PLEASE CALL ON THE CONSENT.
COOLEY WALDRON BANNACK FLORA I
FLOOR AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON HIGHLY WE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MATHIS MATHIS
AYE RUBIO RUBIO HIGH MOTION
PASSES MOTION PASSES THANK YOU
WE ALSO WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY SIMILAR MATHIS WITH A
MISMATCH YOU CAN BEGIN THANK
YOU. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM HERE TO RESENT AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD RECOGNIZE
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION TO
PRIVATELY FUND THE CONSTRUCTION
AND MAINTENANCE OF A GOLD STAR
FAMILIES MONUMENT. ON THE
GROUNDS OF. OUR STATE CAPITOL
THE SIGNIFICANCE AND IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL TO OUR STATE
VETERANS AND THE FAMILIES OF
VETERANS IS REFLECTED IN ITS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COOLEY FLORA
RAMOS AND VOEPEL FOR JOINT
AUTHORING THE BILL WITH ME AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM A LACK.
MEDINA CALAVERAS AND PHILIP
COULD WALK FOR CO AUTHORING THE
MEASURE. THE TITLE OF GOLD STAR
FAMILY IS RESERVED FOR FAMILIES
OF THE MILITARY. MEMBERS WHO
HAVE DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
THE HISTORY OF GOLD STAR
FAMILIES BEGAN IN THE UNITED
STATES SHORTLY AFTER WORLD WAR
ONE. DURING THIS CONFLICT THE
CUSTOMER ROSE ONE FAMILIES OF
SERVICE MEMBERS WOULD HANG A
SERVICE FLAG IN THEIR WINDOWS.
OF THEIR HOMES A BLUE STAR FOR
EVERY LIVING SERVICE MEMBER. A
SILVER STAR FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
WOULD BEEN INJURED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. AND A GOLD STAR FOR
THOSE WHO PAID THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
TWO IS STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
COMMONSENSE MEASURE. THAT WOULD
USE THE SAME LEGAL FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED AN ASSEMBLY
MORALES'S ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE A- THAT WAS CHAPTER LAST
YEAR. MEMBERS THIS BILL PAYS
HOMMAGE TO THE PRACTICE OF OUR
GOLD STAR FAMILIES AND
TRADITIONS OF OUR MILITARY.
CALLING IN TODAY I AM EXTREMELY
HONORED TO HAVE. WOODY WILLIAMS
MEDAL OF HONOR RECIPIENT WORLD
WAR TWO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO. AS BOTH
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL AND A PROUD
VETERAN. MEMBERS I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ARRIVES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MATHIS MODERATE WILL GO
THE PHONE LINES FOR HIS FIRST
WITNESS. DO YOU I DO NOT SHOW-
MISTER WILLIAMS ON THE PHONE
LINE. WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES HERE IN JUST A
MINUTE WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO.
MISTER TERRIBLY WE HAD CHAD
GRAHAM WHO'S ON THE LINE- FOR.
MISTER WILLIAMS- SINCE THIS
ROOMS WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES JUST MENTAL DO THE
COMMUTER IN FIRST. SO YOU GOT TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
I'M DANA NICKEL WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS OUR CLIENTS
THE AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA AMVETS DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL
OF THE UMBRELLA GROUP OF TWENTY
TWO VETERANS SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO. YOU MISTER
GRAHAM YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY ON BEHALF OF MR
WILLIAMS MY NAME IS CHAD GRAHAM
AND  HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING
AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
WILLIAMS FOUNDATION. AND ALSO
HAVE THE UNIQUE HONOR OF BEING
WHAT HE'S GRANDSON- WE ARE ARE
CALLING IN AND BUDGET SPENDING A
DAY IN SUPPORT OF PLACEMENT OF
THE GOLD STAR FAMILIES MEMORIAL
MONUMENT THERE ON CAPITOL
GROUNDS IN CALIFORNIA- THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT. EFFORT TO OUR
GOLD STAR FAMILIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- WE'VE HAD THE UNIQUE
BLESSING OF BEING A PART. OF
NINETY FOUR OF THESE BEING
PLACED ACROSS THE COUNTRY THUS
FAR WITH AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY IN
PROGRESS- SIX OF THOSE LOCATIONS
ARE ON STATE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND
I CAN TELL YOU- FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE STANDING WITH THESE
FAMILIES. AS WE- HONOR THEIR
LOVED ONES THEN MAKE CERTAIN WE
NEVER FORGET- IT IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT TO THEM. THAT THAT IS
REPRESENTED AT THE STATE LEVEL-
WE HAVE ONCE AGAIN SIX STATES
THAT HAVE ELECTED TO PLACE ONE
OF THESE MONUMENTS. BONNER THANK
CAPITOL GROUNDS WE AS AN ENTITY
I HAVE GOT A BILLS AFTERWARDS
HAVE PROVIDED AND FACILITATED
THE PRODUCT FUNDING THAT- WAS
NEEDED FOR THIS PROJECT. AND
WOULD BE EAGER TO ENGAGE AND
SUPPORT- BUSINESS. THAT WE'RE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THIS BELMAR
MODERATORS OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO. SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE OF THEIR
APPEARANCE APART. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO SUPPORT IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT
OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEE NON. BELMONT
WRITER ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMES FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER GIBSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK OFF IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CONSIDER ME AS
BEING A CO AUTHOR. OF THE BILL
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. THIS REVIEW. THANK YOU MISTER
METHODS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I REALLY APPRECIATED- MY
BROTHER JUST GOT OUT OF THE ARMY
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR US. THERE
WAS NO INCIDENTS AND I DO FEEL
FOR THOSE FAMILIES AND- IF I DIE
I CAN ASK FOR TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AS WELL I'D APPRECIATE
IT. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE WAS ABOUT HIS
REPLACE CLOSE. MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT
AND FOR THE ADD ONS. RECOGNIZING
PAYING HOMMAGE TO OUR GOLD STAR
FAMILIES IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY IN A STATE- AS BIG AS
OURS AND I AM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU ARE TRESPASSING SUBJECT A
LITTLE. ON AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TO
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COOLEY WALDRON DANETTE FLORA
FLORA HI FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON NICELY THE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RUBIO
RUBIO IV VALLAPUDUA. COMMISSION
PASSES THE MOTION PASSED WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN JUST FOR A FEW
MINUTES SEE IF OTHER MEMBERS
SHOW UP AN OUT ON- OTHERWISE
WILL RETURN. THANK YOU SIR. YEAH.
ALL RIGHT TERMS WITH THE LOBOLA
WILL GO WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FIRST. SO ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS WE VALLAPUDUA. THE
VALLAPUDUA HI THE MOTION PASSES
MOTION PASSES. MOVING ON TO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO HI AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO MATHIS BE
APPROVED BY THE VALLAPUDUA I
MISS ABOUT THE MOTION PASSES
THANK YOU THIS MEETINGS ADJOURN.